Open
Iopchi We're different in middle school, so we have to make efforts to make different
friends.
In order to do that, first of all, say hello cheerfully, chin me
can
, there's no bullet left
If we share our troubles, there's no way we won't get along well
huh
Hanasaki might
be able to make friends I'm here to love my car and my head  Rou
Genji
I'm happy to hear that you want to be my friend
Hunter
end I didn't say don't ride back and
let's do this re
[music]
nani Our
whole life will start broadcasting in January
me
let's go home
ah mobo  I'm having so much fun that I'm writing a certain designation
me
Make a friend This
is to come to like the social conditions of your favorite car Genji
friend